jean michel lambert c'est bien la
première fois que je vais procéder à
l'interrogatoire d'un juge d'instruction
j'ai vu dans france soir qui ont
dizaines de gens vers devant le
procureur qui voit là et je dois vous
avouer que je préfère vous interviewez
que de l'interroger plutôt que l'
inverse parce que ça évidemment serait
pas bon signe pour moi si c'est l
inverse
alors avez vous avez vous remarqué que
le verbe commettre s'emploie à la fois
pour un crime et pour un livre l'avez
remarqué alors et avez vous l'impression
d'avoir commis un livre ou pas d'avoir
écrit à lyon fait d'avoir commis et
alors pourquoi pourquoi avez vous écrit
un livre comme celui ci est ce que parce
que vous êtes vous devenu vous même une
vedette de la sphère villemin normandie
si vous n'aviez pas été le juge
d'instruction de l'affairé villemin est
donc devenu à cause de cette affaire
célèbre auriez vous pensé écrire les
histoires la vie quotidienne d'un juge
d'instruction
sincèrement je pense que oui mais il est
certain que l'impact n'aurait pas été le
même parce qu'un juge de province
n'auraient pas eu la chance d'être connu
oui c'est à dire que beaucoup de
magistrats attendent la retraite pour
dire leurs souvenirs
voilà ces problèmes en ce que vous
auriez fait et peut-être auriez-vous eu
du mal à trouver un éditeur si vous
n'aviez pas je n'étais pas devenu
célèbre par l'affairé villemin assez
sage convient tout à fait oui tout à
fait bon alors la sphère villemagne on
occupe une part très modeste donne dans
le livre ah oui parce que je suis donc
lié par le secret d'instruction dont je
ne peux rien dire sur le fond du dossier
et je n'aborde que les aspects que je
peux donc évoqué un savoir bon et les
lettres anonymes reçues et puis
l'analyse de la sphère dans les rapports
avec les médias
bon alors la sphère villemin en
apparence bien thaler mais vous raconter
beaucoup d'autres affaires qui sont
passées pendant votre commande est votre
ministère demande une autre
non bon pas bon pendant vos activités
qui ont commencé quand dans l'église
s'est vrillé 1904 80 alors on vous dit
au départ ben vous allez voir ce les
vosges d'un département il se passe pas
grand chose
et puis quand on voit tout ce que vous
racontez que de crimes que le viol que
de sens que de haine et c'est absolument
effrayant c'est la même chose comme ça
dans tous les coups et on est tombé très
bas c'est partout pareil absolument
absolument tous les juges d'instruction
les 550 collègues environ juge
d'instruction de france ont chacun dans
leurs cabinets d affaires du même ordre
mais il fait absolument effrayant alors
vous n'êtes pas vous raconter que vous
avez eu une enfance très protégé assez
douillette et tout d'un coup vous passer
de cette enfance douillette à un monde
de 200 de haine avec même des autopsies
auquel vous assistez et chivu le lève le
coeur est ce que je me disais au fond en
lisant votre i je me disais ce qu' il
n'aurait pas mieux valu vous ayez eu une
enfance peut être un peu plus difficile
un peu plus chahutées parce que le
contrat serait peut-être été moins
saisissant peut-être mais disons qu'il y
à des événements comme ceux ci fort
désagréable auquel nom ne finit jamais
par s'y habituer mais bon ça fait partie
du travail mais par exemple les les
autopsies auxquels vous devez assister
tout à fait tout à fait un jeu j'évoque
cette odeur de la mort qui est quelque
chose d'absolument abominable et qui
imprègne après les vêtements et on vous
avait dit à l'école le jour
bien sûr d'ailleurs à l'école nous avons
tous assisté à au moins une autopsie
ça fait partie du travail est alors vous
raconter d'ailleurs je le dis avec
beaucoup de détails et les autopsies et
les viols 1up pas que ça a pas que ça
aurait nommé parce qu'elle voulait
raconter avec beaucoup de détails je me
suis demandé pourquoi on n'y voyait
aucune mauvaise intention de noms
demeurent non qu'ils me disent ah bon la
miss vient alors les ce que je peux être
commis un livre mais ce n'est pas bon
est-ce que
est-ce que la sphère villemin bon qui
vous a rendu célèbres du cem elle a
rendu tous les gens célèbres de tous les
gens qui s'occupent l affaire villemin
sont devenus des gens célèbres
évidemment les suspects le les les
journalistes le juge d'instruction
certains policiers etc
les avocats est-ce que vous pensez que
ce n'est pas quand même quelque chose de
condamnable que tout le monde soit
devenue une des stars grâce à cette
affaire abominable et je rappelle au
départ c'est quand même le meurtre d'un
enfant car absolument absolument ça
c'est un élément qu'il ne faut pas
perdre de vue s condamnable c'est
difficile à dire c'est nous avons tous
été confrontés à ce problème est
effectivement nous sommes tous devenus
entre guillemets des des stars le mot
est vraiment à mettre entre guillemets
malgré nous mais bien l'impression que
la fere villemin dans votre vie
professionnelle
c'est une chance ou c'est une malchance
non pour sûr on ne peut pas employer le
mot chance ça ne peut pas employer le
mot chance vous pouvez pas en prix non
plus le mot malchance non je crois que
on peut pas raisonner en termes ceux là
dessus de chance ou de malchance
c'est un coup du sort un coup du sort du
destin vous dit ceci onze mois plus tard
g6 trail autopsie d'un autre enfant âgé
de 4 ans et demi grégory victime d'un
assassinat que seul pouvait expliquer
une forme de folie
quel qu'en fût l'auteur un crime qui ne
regardaient peut-être pas la justice des
hommes
j'ai été très surpris que vous qui était
censé vous occupez la justice des hommes
tout d'un coup vous avez fière de vous
décharger sur dieu ou le ciel de ces
noms non sur une forme de folie oui mais
quand vous dis un crime qui ne
regardaient peut-être pas la justice des
hommes tous les crimes on regarde la
justice oui ça m'a roulé noir mais là
vous avez tout à fait raison tout à fait
raison mais ceci dit effectivement il ya
peut-être des nuances à introduire et
peut-être qu'effectivement ce crime ne
regarde pas la justice
mais comment mais c'est étonnant quand
même la bouche d'un juge d'instruction
non ça je ne peux pas en dire plus
bon comment expliquez-vous la
extraordinaire médiatisation de ceux de
l' affaire villemin
je crois pour une raison bien simple
j'ai souvent lu que des journalistes
écrire qu'au départ c'était un banal
fait divers
or en fait non c'est un fait divers qui
n'a jamais été banane en raison d'une
composante essentielle dans qu'au départ
de la faire quitter le l'existence la
présence d'un corbeau parce que ce qu'on
appelait entre guillemets le corbeau et
je crois d affaire de corbeau bon il y
en avait déjà vu dans le l'histoire
judiciaire française
mais tout ce contexte avec donc c'est
assassinats d'enfants qui avaient donc
été prémédité revendiquer juste avant
revendiquer juste après je crois c'est
ce qui a transformé donc entre
guillemets un banal fait divers qui veut
être un assassinat l'enfant entre les
divers extraordinaire c'est vrai que
tout le monde a concouru à la
médiatisation de ce fait divers de ce
crime atroce par exemple les avocats
mlle n'ai pas beaucoup les avocats au
nom jetant éponyme comment alors d'abord
vous n'aimez pas les avocats parisiens
qui descendent comme des stars kari bhl
la veille d'une affaire et qui se font
payer grassement et qui regardent à
peine le dossier avant d'aller plaider a
su oui ça je pourrais vous retrouvez
projet mais pour des faits moins sûr je
vais le retrouver
le et vous dites aussi par exemple que
la presse la presse courent de grands
risques d'être utilisés par des avocats
peu scrupuleux pour assurer le relais de
la défense leurs clients clim en clamant
son innocence estimant sa dent dans
l'avenir oui donc les avocats bhl sont
quand même et perd les journalistes
suivent il est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas le
beau rôle non plus ce qui est normal et
je dirais pour les acca billet un peu
encore pour nous en ont maintenant pas
quand même miser jeu des égratignures
les et gratuit
oui et puis vous avez craqué devant eux
oui vous avez cédé vous avez cédé vous
aussi au prestige de la notoriété
vous savez c'est plus compliqué ce n'est
pas en termes de de notoriété que l'on
peut parler c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que cela quand vous êtes seul pendant
des mois dans une affaire comme ça et
que l'on vous chez miroiter bon un
article plaisant le fêter on sait on sen
j'ai retrouvé le passage
oui à l'issue de son interrogatoire de
première comparution françois j avais
choisi une avocate du bureau d'epinal
pour assurer sa défense
quelques jours avant la session des
assises accord il s'adjoindre les
services d'un autre ténor du barreau
parisien
j'apprendrai que ce cher homme
commencera par demander 20 mille francs
d'honoraires qu'il arrivera epinal
veille du grand jour qui découvrira
étudiera le dossier dans la nuit
françois j sera condamné à 4 années
d'emprisonnement même dans les affaires
prime passionnel j'ai juré bon gageons
que s'il avait oui d'accord oui non mais
je mange de crise mais c'est alors qu'un
exemple bon nous avons un jury populaire
l'a alors philippe labro kg je me pose
des questions sur ce livre et je suis
pas seul parce que vous avez lu dans la
presse qu'un savant le magistrat qui se
pose des questions si vous parlez aux
550 collègues je vous demande simplement
si vous auriez dû l'écrire
sa première question d'une question
j'aimerais bien savoir pourquoi vous
mentionnez jamais bernard laroche
et puis la troisième question c
que je crois que vous avez trop tendance
à accabler les autres à la télé en
prenant leur dawn est ce que vous aviez
raison de l'écrire
écoutez j'ai voulu témoigner des moines
y est sûre ce qui est de la justice
contemporaine j'aurais pu le faire en
écrivant un livre qui se serait appelée
la vie quotidienne la juge d'instruction
ces juges et peut-être à temps mais j'ai
agi suivant mon tempérament
deux employés le jeu de dire voilà moi
et jean michel lambert entre guillemets
juge d'instruction epinal voici ce qui
m'est arrivé
voici ce qui m'arrivait avant le 16
octobre 84
voici ce qui m'est arrivé voilà comment
les choses se passent moi j'ai pas été
élevé dans l'idée que les juges
d'instruction devait révéler une grande
partie se prennent naissance et leur
métier mon île la justice n'est pas la
porte n'avait pas à mon avis vous n'avez
pas tout à fait raison que ça ne les
rend pas peut-être que si on à la
justice le célèbre la justice est rendue
au nom du peuple français
les français ne connaissent pas la
justice ils ne savent pas comment
fonctionnent ils
pardon vous croyez que la police montée
a recueilli 1 je pense ne connaissent
pas le tous les rois je ne parle pas des
des jeux
qu'ils jugent où siègent je ne parle pas
des parcs et mais je pense que
concernant l'instruction ils en sauront
un peu plus deuxième question
l'étonnement vous n'avez pas de bernard
laroche folha kyi a été inculpée
absolument que vous avez exacte des
actionneurs du soleil et puis qui
ensuite a été tuée relâché et tuée par
son beau-frère a fait mais alors là
c'est un drame d'abord je n'en parle pas
et je sais la réplique et vous allez me
dire je n'en parle pas parce que la
chaîne n'ait pas jugé
alors si rapide qu'on va pas la dire
dans ce cas là si l'afer n'est pas jugée
pourquoi être la cerise en tout cas pour
pouvoir mettre deux chapitres sur la
sphère savagnac de chapitres et qui
analyse des aspects tout à fait honnête
l affaire s kiddies vos collègues les
amis sont semble-t-il très partagés
plutôt même hostile je vous dire ce qui
est bon que vous ressentez vous avez une
année sabbatique là vous reprendrez
votre métier de juge à la fin de l'année
où sont les miens attention oui le 1er
janvier 80 mais à epinal ah non non ça
je serais nommé un dur c'est le meilleur
mais vous pensez pas alors que toute
votre vie professionnelle de juges vous
serez le petit juge celui qui a instruit
l'affairé villemin celui qui a écrit ce
livre et ses pensées si c'est certain
que ça me manquera
et vous pensez pas d'ailleurs que ça va
changer un petit peu là la manière dont
vous allez procéder que les avocats les
inculpés ne seront pas devant vous comme
il serait devant un autre juge
d'instruction soit tout à fait et ça
n'est pas gênant l'avenir le dira mais
c'est sûr que ça sera très difficile
très difficile j'ai vu ça que philippe
bouvard raconté qu'un jour vous êtes
venu la voir et vous lui avez demandé
comme comment faire pour devenir célèbre
j'ai même lu ce bar le canard enchaîné
de services ben non alors ça je démens
totalement
il est exact que j'avais rencontré
philippe bauer à ma demande au mois de
mai 1980 vous savez monsieur labro clé
les magistrats ont des formations
continues et donc peuvent passer une
semaine dans un organe de presse
j'aurais pu donc c'est l'école qui
choisit j'aurais pu aller rtn
je vois pu aller au monde et l'école ma
vie trouver un stage à france soir donc
étant à france soir
j'ai tourné dans différents services il
est exact que j'ai demandé à rencontrer
monsieur philippe bauer que je tenais
pour un très grand professionnel est
vrai de ce qui devrait vous tenez où
tiens le jour
je vous accorde le tient en revanche de
record le juge lambert parce que
d'ordinaire dans le récit de ce genre
d'affaires criminelles
on pleure on pleure sur l'enfant qui a
été tué ou bien on pleure sur la mer si
elle est innocent du crime dont on
l'accuse et lisant ce livre tout à coup
on pleure sur le juge
mais pour dire non ce n'est pas du tout
et c'est un livre qui qui fait qu'ils
vraiment apitoie sur le rôle du juge et
enfin c'était quasiment à la lecture ce
qu'il faut dire
bon je vous ayez un petit avocat quand
même ici et puis je vois comme des cons
je vous savez de plusieurs journalistes
bien ce que journaliste j'ai pas
toujours apprécié la façon dont ils sont
traités dans le livre du juge lambert
mais je crois que c'est l'organisation
de la justice française qui est
imputable car
elle est organisée de telle façon d'un
jeu de magistrats qui sortent l'école
qui a eu cette jeunesse protégé qui
connaît rien de la vie se trouve
brusquement envoyé dans un pays où le
terroir est très fort où les gens ont
des moeurs secrète un peu rustique qu'il
ne connaît pas qu'elle est complètement
étranger et qui brusquement se voit
apporté dans son cabinet d'instruction
une affaire tragique particulièrement
tragique et là je crois que la justice
dans ces cas là est un peu coupable de
délégués autant de pouvoir à quelqu'un
qui n'a pas ni les compétences ni la
formation morale et intellectuelle pour
assumer les tâches qu'il est préparé ni
à l'horreur ni à la célèbre seulement
alors simplement c'est vrai que ça a été
beaucoup critiqués parce que raconter
quand vous inculper christine villemin
vous pleurez avant vous dites voilà j'ai
pleuré d'une fois qu'elle est inculpé
vous pleurez encore après et vous dites
même que cela perturbe votre vie
sexuelle
bon moi j'ai trouvé bon il ya des gens
qui se moquent de cet aveu moi pas très
franchement je trouve que c'est faut
beaucoup de courage pour avouer ce genre
de choses parce qu'effectivement c'est
on s'en moque assez facilement les
larmes la juge d'instruction
quelqu'un qui vient avec une inculpé et
puis même c'est cette inculpation qui
vient troubler sa vie intime tout ça est
un et se préparer moi j'ai plutôt été un
peu émue l'a plutôt que payer un assez
pitoyable par le par le rôle que tient
le juge est parée par cette mission qui
finalement je crois que la vraie
question c'est de savoir si monsieur ou
jean michel lambert était fait pour être
une instruction alors quelle est la
réponse et il vous fait pour être juge
d'instruction j'ai le sentiment que oui
et étiez et pensez vous pas que c'est de
la faire est arrivé trop tôt dans votre
vie professionnelle
peut-être peut-être mais ça c'est une
affaire comme ça
on en rencontre une fois tous les 20 ou
30 ans est ce que vous dites pas
justement dans votre vivre avec la
candeur qui aux caractérisques que
justement vos professeurs à l'école ou
quand vous avez passé un examen ont bien
précisé qu'il n'était pas fait pour ce
métissage est aussi lui sont alors on
dit ou pas ah non non non je les lui à
voile avec moi je suis le canard
enchaîné et sage jusqu'à preuve du
contraire alors on va terminer avec